check out this week's must English it's  just me a friendly neighborhood  spider-man Peter Parker has to balance  his superhero alter ego with normal high  school life in the spider-man homecoming  they work in secret and under constant  threats they are real journalistic  heroes  the untold story of a group of  journalists fighting against Isis in the  documentary Sidious go horns Casey  Affleck stars in a ghost story a surreal  indie drama about a recently deceased  man whose spirit watches over his  breathing life we do we kill your door  see what's hot in theaters with this  week's anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]